I'm Sandra and I have the recovery well
which is in Ramsgate and Turner Street
I've got the therapy business which is
complementary therapies doing Swedish
massage hot stone massage pregnancy
massage and reflexology of various types
and aromatherapy I also have rooms here
which one of them we are sitting in just
now
um For Hire so at the moment I have a
psychotherapist who comes in one morning
a week and another lady coming starting
on Friday who works for cancer charity I
also has a well-being shop and that sort
of grew organically I started off by
wanting to just offer oils and things to
my clients and then when I got this
place they already had a shop there so
now I've got a huge product range mostly
eco-friendly fair trade products that's
been my thoughts right from the
beginning everything that I've done with
the renovation is all upcycled and also
within my therapy treatments I use as
much as I can that's you know
eco-friendly and sustainable
being on my own with two young children
I was thinking if I go back to what I
did previously which was Recruitment and
that would be awful for them as well
because you know they're long hours by
the time I traveled and everything I
barely see them at all
and so I decided to look at changing my
career so I thought about what I'd like
to do decided to take A New Path and I
just threw myself into it basically and
then doing the lockdowns I did a lot of
additional training as well I was able
to get my hands on this place which was
amazing and now I've been open coming
close to two years now or 18 months
foreign
speaking and knowing the little
Independence around Ramsgate
we bring something unique to the area we
bring a bit of an energy something
different that you're not going to find
in the big stores that you're going to
be left with if we all go and also just
the personal contact really you know you
know that I'm here and you can have a
chat with me or I know that you're going
to be looking for something so I find it
for you there's much more of a
personalized service and I think those
sorts of levels of service
won't come with the big companies you
know it's all off the shelf stuff
literally so it's really important to
keep the locals alive and that's the
only way that that can be done is by
people using them
[Music]